rule-based authorization is the
cornerstone of any user moderated site a
good example is Stack Overflow which
provides users various privileges based
on the amount of reputation that they've
gained on the site in this episode I'm
going to show you how to use angular 5
and firestore to build your own
role-based authorization feature my goal
is to give you a solution that is both
flexible and secure on the front end and
the back end it works by assigning a
role to a user that saved in fire store
then that role is used to walk down
certain actions in angular the default
role is a subscriber which only has the
ability to read data then we have an
editor that can read and update data and
of course an admin user that can read
update create and delete if you're brand
new to the channel make sure to
subscribe and you can follow along with
the source code at angular firebase com
I'm starting from a brand new angular
app with angular fire two installed you
can find the install instructions on the
official repo the first thing I'm going
to do is generate a core module to
isolate all the logic for authentication
and authorization then inside that
module I'm going to generate a service
called the auth service now before we
get into the actual auth code I want to
warn you that I'm going to go through it
very quickly because I covered it in
episode 55 which was fires store Roth
if you get lost refer back to that but
let's quickly review the sign-in signup
process first I'm going to import our
angular fire libraries and then I'm
going to define a custom user interface
but before we define the user let's
actually define our roles as I mentioned
before the three roles that we have our
subscriber editor and admin the roles
will be saved as an object in fire store
with each possible role being set to a
boolean value this allows you to assign
multiple roles to a single user if
that's what you desire then on the user
itself we'll just have a user ID and
email and then the roles property will
be set to this roles object interface
let's go ahead and switch back to the
service and then we can set up an
observable that is type two this user
interface to authenticate a user and use
that fire store document we'll first
listen to the angular fire off state and
once we get that we can then retrieve
the actual user document from fire store
so if the user is defined then we'll
pull that document from fire store and
call value changes to get it as an
observer
otherwise what is returned and
observable at null from there we need a
way for the user to authenticate so
we're just going to use Google OAuth for
this example and when the user
successfully authenticates we're going
to run this update user data method the
purpose of that method is to create or
update the user document in firestore
the way we do that is we create a
reference to the actual user document
with the authentication user ID and then
we can set up an object here type to our
user with a default role of subscriber
then we can update this data without
actually overriding it by calling that
reference set and then pass it the merge
true option this will create or update
the existing document in a
non-destructive way so at this point we
have a basic authentication system but
we still don't have any role based rules
in our app what I've done is created a
couple extra components here this one
happens to pull some data from firestore
and we'll set up rules that prevent the
user from updating or deleting this post
the test post just has some content and
a title property then I set up another
component called the super secret
component that's only for admin users
and that's where we keep all of our
bitcoins the way I like to implement
rule-based authorization is to create a
set of abilities and then assign those
abilities various roles that are
authorized to perform them what I'm
doing first is creating a helper method
that takes the user and the allowed
roles from one of these abilities and
we'll check and see if the user has the
appropriate role to perform it so if the
user is not defined then we'll just
return false otherwise we're going to
loop over the allowed roles and if the
user has that role then we can return
true otherwise we'll just return false
now I'm going to define the abilities
right here in the service but you could
extract this out into its own class if
you have a really complex set of roles
and abilities so the first one is can
read and this will determine if a user
can read a document or not so right now
the admin editor and subscriber all have
access to read as you'll see later we
can use this method to easily hide or
block content in our components or in a
router guard to easily control access
throughout the application now we can
repeat this pattern for whatever ability
is that we want to provide to these
roles so I'll go ahead and create
another one here for can
edit and then I'll create one more for
can delete which is only allowed to be
performed by the admin user keep in mind
that anything you do in angular only
provides front-end security it would be
trivial to reverse engineer and
circumvent these rules so before we do
anything on the front-end we're going to
write some back-end rules in firestore
that will guarantee data security what
we want to see is the spire Store error
whenever we try to read or write any
unauthorized data currently I don't have
any security on the test post in my fire
store rules in the firebase console but
I'm going to use the get method to
retrieve a document from the fire store
database based on this request auth user
ID so that authenticated users document
is going to have the roles object so we
can read the data then look at the roles
and for the subscriber we want to make
sure that that value is true in other
words if the current user tries to read
this document but they don't have the
subscriber role then it's going to block
access to that document the one glaring
problem here is that this line is super
long and it's going to get completely
out of control if we try to repeat it
for multiple roles
luckily fire store rules allow you to
write functions so we can write this in
a much more readable and expressive way
I'm going to create this get role
function that takes the role as a string
as an argument then I'm going to repeat
that whole get line that I wrote just a
second ago but instead of calling
subscriber will call the argument from
this function now we can just delete the
previous rule and we can rewrite it
using this function so we'll say if get
roll with the subscriber roll and that
should equal true then we can do the
same thing for the editor and admin
roles as well and we can lock these down
based on the type of operation so we can
say allow update if get role editor
equals true and then for admin we'll say
allow create or delete if the admin role
equals true now I'm going to go into
fire store on the user document and
update their editor role to true then
I'm going to log into the app and if I
try to delete a page I should still get
an error because they don't have the
admin privilege however if this user
performs an update then it goes through
in fire store and doesn't trigger any
kind of error in the console that's how
you keep your data 100% secure in fire
store but it's better if we never have
to trigger these rules in the first
place
I'm jumping over to a component called
subscribe page and this is where we're
pulling the actual test pose from fire
store so I have a reference and a post
observable and then I have a variable
for the user itself if you want to walk
down a specific method in the component
you can subscribe to the user during ng
on an it and then use it to lock down
certain code based on whatever users
have that ability I'm going to create a
couple methods here one to edit a post
and another to delete a post then if you
want to lock down a method based on a
certain ability you can just do if can
edit and pass it the user object then
just wrap the important part inside of
this if statement that's one way to use
the auth service but it's actually a lot
easier if you perform this logic inside
of the template itself in most cases you
have buttons or other elements that the
user will interact with to trigger some
kind of method we can just hide these
elements from the Dom using ng-if and
are off service and that's usually a
much more maintainable way to go but
there's actually still an even better
mechanism that we can use in angular to
prevent unauthorized access to content
and that's what the router guard to lock
down certain routes based on the user's
role so first I'm going to create a
guard called the admin guard and add
that to the core module inside the guard
I'm going to import our auth service as
well as tap map and take from rxjs then
the auth service is injected in the
constructor and we're going to return an
observable from this guard inside of can
activate and it's important that you map
this observable to a boolean so first
we'll call pipe and then we'll pipe in a
few are X operators here first one is
take one to prevent a running
subscription then inside a map we'll see
if the user object exists and if so
we'll also check for the user roles
object for the admin property then we'll
do a ternary if statement here and
return true if true otherwise false then
we can use that tap operator which
recently replaced the do operator to
console.log an error if the user is
trying to access an unauthorized area
but you could also use the router here
to redirect the user to a different
route so this is going to lock down a
route based on a certain role but we can
also lock down round a certain ability
because if you remember multiple roles
can be assigned to a specific ability
all of the codes exactly the same we
just have to change one thing down here
in the map operator so instead of
looking at the actual role itself will
pass the user to the can read method
from our off service and that will
authorize any roles that can read a
document to put these guards to use will
go into the router and then we'll import
the guards and add them to the can
activate array and each of the route
objects if you can lock things down at
the route level it's going to simplify
your code base overall and it also has
the added benefit of not requiring a
read in fire store to see if a rule
evaluates to true or false as you can
see here we have an unauthenticated user
and they are denied access to any of
these pages just based on the router
guard then if we log in with the editor
role we can go to the main content page
but that admin page is still locked down
so on a final note just to sum up the
bottom line you should be using back end
fire scorer rules for your actual data
security and then on the front end use
router guards and additional logic to
enhance the user experience that's it
for role based access control with fire
store if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want to
learn more consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase com look at
access to exclusive content a free copy
of my book and one on one project
support thanks for watching and I'll see
you soon
[Music]